what's going on guys national master james canton
iii here with chess.com and today we have the top
five blunders yes the best in the world still
blunders sometimes the top five blunders and
the speed chess championships this first game is
actually cargo nakamura versus magnus carlson back
in 2016 in the speedchest championship let's
see what happens here so icaru actually is
uh under some fire here his queen is attacked
as we see here he has double rooks on the file
the c5 pawn is actually hit but his queen is the
immediate piece that he has to move right now
so where do you think you would move your
queen here why to move what do you actually do
here we go this is what car would chose queen
of four get out of the way right i'm fine i
have some moves okay maybe queen h4 could be a
thing maybe even back up to queen f3 if i have
to but queen f4 but now you have to notice that
the queen is short on spaces when you see a queen
short on spaces like here here here here you don't
have any squares to really go to maybe this one
what do we do you attack it g5 the game's
over already and he resigns in this position
can you believe it guys very very easy queen f5
the queen's attacked queen f4 and g5 and the queen
is trapped and this was example number one now
let's move on to example number two now in this
next example we have alexander grishik with white
pieces versus magnus carlsen with the black pieces
back in 2016. let's actually see what happened
here so if you see this position right here black
or magnus is actually giving some problems down
here on the back rank the king is slightly safe
but things like f4 maybe we could do this there's
some things that's happening for both sides of the
board here actually there's a pass pawn coming too
so you have to be active you have to do something
so magnus chose f4 here which is a very strong
move here bishop takes h3 is the immediate threat
followed by queen takes f1 so either pawn capture
would be bishop takes h3 so actually alexander
grisham chose queen two h4 here after queen h4
he's just saying hey look you can't take on h3
you're i'm totally fine if you play f3 i'm
actually just gonna probably back up king to g1
and then if if uh king g1 and bishop takes
c4 which is actually pinning then we have
queen takes e4 check followed by queen takes
c4 but what happens here is he doesn't realize
he has blundered he has blundered the game
is over after this next move can you find it
the game is over guys if you chose g5 whoa you are
thinking just like magnus this is a blunder g5 the
game's over and he resigns as the queen is trapped
has no squares to go to the light squares are
covered by the dark square queen here or the dark
queen here the black queen and queen g4 you can't
play here obvious reasons bishop takes and that's
it the queen has nowhere else to go so he resigns
in this position a blunder guys it does happen to
the best of us now let's move on to example number
three and here we are guys with example number
three or should we say blunder number three in
this game we have hikaru nakamura with the white
pieces versus the world champion magnus carlson
this was in 2018 let's see what's going on on
the board here now it's black to move here black
has some choices to make magnus has some things
to do he has a very active rook here that could
help maybe in some cases of rook to g5 bishop h3s
but we have to figure out what we do what we're
doing here and this rook is kind of weird here
on e5 but it could help us but magnus actually
chose a move here there was an immediate blunder
that ended the game on the spot here he actually
chose can you believe it guys d take c4 seems like
a simple move here we actually may follow up with
rook to d5 you can't take this way you would
have to take with the pawn followed by maybe
bishop f5 we put some pressure onto this bishop
because the queen's pinned or is the queen pinned
white to move guys have you done your tactics
today what would you play here in this position
why to move can you believe it guys bishop takes
eight seven oh my goodness a regular tactic here
something that the world champion even fell
for half man have everything else it's okay
sometimes they blunder too but here it
definitely hurt bishop takes h7 check
followed by king takes or knight takes no matter
which piece you take with and we're taking the
queen and hikaru nakamura wins on the spot as
magnus resigns in this position from a blunder
now let's move on to example number four all
right guys and here we go for example number
four this is alexander grishik with the white
pieces playing against magnus carlsen in 2017.
let's actually see what's going on on the board
here white is doing some scary things to the king
here there's making two threats everywhere
i mean these past pawns look very scary here
and it's black to move so magnet just says hey
we gotta check you we have to do something here
and he actually chose a very nice check
because there's very limited moves here
guys you have to you have to like be aware of
what's going on you have to probably go king h4
because of king 2h5 then there's mate on h3 and
it king to f5 well then we actually check here and
after king to e5 we have queen to g3 followed by
skewering the king and the queen here nice skewer
so but the move actually chosen was queen to g3 by
grishak here but this is a blunder queen g3 how is
it a blunder how is it a blunder can you actually
see why this is a blunder guys black to move
here it is guys it's just taking the queen
it's just taking the queen guys literally
just taking the queen because he blunders into now
a losing ending what do you mean losing it looks
like white's crushing here well let's watch the
rest of it a5 this is now a losing end game for
white this is not even a draw after c5 because
he has to get the pawns rolling you have to do
something here king e7 and surprisingly this king
can stop the pawns what are you serious absolutely
the king can absolutely stop all three of these
pawns if you push this one i take this one
if you push this one then i'll take and then i'll
take this one and i'll be able to get back when
you want to run this one so let's see what he
does king f4 a4 that pawn's running king a5 a3
pass pawns must be pushed then we have d6 check he
just backs up it's nothing to it you push this one
i step up you push the other one i step in king
d7 and this pawn helps me a lot luckily this pawn
is here on b7 to actually hold here now after king
to d7 there's king to d5 and a2 and he resigns
in this position because there's nothing to do
there is nothing to do you can't stop the queen
at this point unbelievable guys unbelievable if
you actually look at this position right here
you would never think that white could lose this
position but you actually clan it you actually
can it was a bl it was a blunder here queen to
g3 seems like it's the only move you actually
have king h4 but queen to g3 captures going into
a losing ending guys unbelievable this is why you
should study your end games and even the best of
the best fail and blunder as well as we see here
this very nice fashion here we're going to queen
and the game is completely over guys this was
100 a blunder very very sneaky blunder to say the
least book magnus was able to find and convert
this game and that was example number four blunder
number four now we move on to the final example
now in this final example guys this final blunder
we have hikaru nakamura versus sergey gregorians
now in this position actually this was back in
2017 here um we actually have black to move here
so this bishop's hanging but also he could capture
first and that's actually what he chose he said
rick takes d1 but he actually missed an
in-between move guys and in between origins
he missed the in-between move that actually
costs him the game rook takes d1 is just
a blunder why why is it a blunder guys pretty
self-explanatory let's see if you can find it
here it is knight takes c5 with check with check
now you have to go towards the king towards the
knight here because if you don't play king e7
or f6 we just take the rook and this is easy
like let's just start a new game i'm already up
a piece here why are we still playing this game
king to d6 he has to go towards the knight here so
he can capture it but we actually have another in
between move knight takes b7 check thank you
for the pawn and after king to c7 rook takes
and then after you take here's another pawn thank
you so much for the pawn here and now we go into
a winning ending but it does take technique so
let's see his technique rick f6 just absolutely
uh threatening both of the pawns here keeping
the king kinda at bay rook to b8 and we actually
choose a very sharp move here as he always finds
rook to e6 a threatening rook takes c5 check
really grabbing this pawn so we can grab this
one as well and have a a central pass pawn ready
to go rook to b3 and then rook takes c5 king to c4
take the other one now we have a central pass pawn
and another pass pawn he didn't even bother these
guys sometimes you don't even need to bother the
other pawns it's just hey where can i create the
fastest pass pawns and go with it rick takes c3
we bring the rook to the back rank here we're
gonna push and we're gonna push you can't stop
both c5 he tries to push his own then we have
a5 rook a3 a6 king d4 a7 threatening check
either way you can't do anything you need to
shelter your king so he does king c3 no checks and
then he plays e5 c4 uh in e6 and then rook to a6
and after uh he's threatening to take with check
actually so then king to f1 he moves out of the
way and there's no way to stop everything if rook
takes we just move our rook out of the way because
this rook was doing a good job of defending and
if you do nothing i'm just going to push this
pawn and then if you're trying to push yours i'm
actually queening before you even get close and
then the game's over from there so he resigned in
this position guys now imagine this of course
this doesn't look as scary as you think it is
but after rook takes d1 knight takes c5 that
in between move guys make sure you look for the
checks and captures and in between moves digits
and jugs that may happen in your own games and
this was a blunder here by one of the best
knight takes c5 king to d6 and hikaru wins
in great fashion after two in-between moves to
finish off the game to get a winning in-game
from here guys winning in-game and he won
in great fashion and this was the top five
blunders guys even the best of the best the
half man have everything else's that we have
here in uh our chess world they blundered
two as well this was the top five blunders
i'm national master james canty the third
and i'll see you guys on the next video